hello and welcome to this video playing
Thomas Tallis and he's our book I heard
back in it yo Elkind you don't see so
often so it's not so easy Jim
maybe we collect what you're actually
playing there we place the four pawns
this is going to be dangerous for me
because I have no idea okay
[Music]
yeah I know that g6 is a move I don't
even know if it is good but I wonder if
I take it I wonder if you can take with
the D pawn actually F context okay I
mean this looks fine but D pawn takes I
was kind of worried maybe here I also
need to worry but I don't here I feel I
get to get to destroy the center in
typical and a coin style web play knight
c6 is possibly e6 still I still think
it's a move to play some from one far
better coordination
[Music]
now g5f 95 so it's not not a big problem
that's a tough position
so get six material is equal here my
ideas maybe Nyjah forward the right
board hmm why does that even work is
there no one a chief what doesn't work
okay
Quinn TX looks very strange 95 so ever
and now now there's nothing particularly
great here and we should have three now
maybe now not too happy here not too
happy
a five is even B 5
[Music]
maybe this for some beef I've move I
[Music]
don't know that that might be
interesting here I have nyjah form or a
form in this position now g4 doesn't
actually do all that much and maybe it
does actually I have some this move
Bishop III to d4 it could be some
counter play so feels like a very
problematic position maybe I can go
Bishop f4 it could be interesting also
try to take them yeah it's it's the most
logical continuation for white okay okay
at least this Bishop now is somewhat
active and maybe I can do something with
this thing Luke takes d4 now is on the
cards but I have the small yeah
yeah now that doesn't look bad now he's
got some coordination issues what to do
I can't even go Queen here Luke takes
the screen f1 checkmate so that doesn't
work
now all of a sudden this looks actors
home k92 now is the next threat which is
not it's not really decisive now they
don't have good square so this is the
only squarely and that looks strange
I can go night see to here and if you
take that's a draw maybe droysen
goodwitch my time is ticking down and I
don't don't see anything great it takes
it Queen everyone is going to be a draw
perpetual check I think you know what
has to take I'm also threatening to take
before here so he probably has to accept
the draw I don't know maybe yes find
something better it don't see it at the
moment and you should just take it a
draw is not bad film
but I understand that she looks of
course Jim I don't have anything else
just a draw
yeah check check check check check check
blue Oh Jeff I really hope for more
somehow but when I got all the active
pieces I really hope for Mohammad maybe
there wasn't
yeah the opening was entirely
unsuccessful ready for me it is looked
that looked not little too good I mean
that that position really sucks okay
Anna Queen c7 are still quite liked by
the computer now camera and I am
interested in this sound part of the
game I mean I really felt like I was
getting somewhere or just Nyjah for win
so uh of course
ha ha ll move that move really looked
wrong Queen b3 somehow that I made you
fall I know giving up and was it was bad
just not you friend it's over now much
here and it isn't as good as it might
look I don't and I have to do this space
okay there is no real alternative
okay so after one opportunity where
could windows magic Warren and we have
this finally funny drawing with the
perpetual okay guys thanks for watching